hey everyone
as you may know there was a very
interesting
neuralink announcement and update
with the progress they've been making
which was
super fun to watch and
to get inspired by
because there seems to be a lot of
fear that is consuming people
around the advances technology
is making and it's important to
ground arse individually and
collectively
in flourishing and prosperity uh
rather than that fear and
entrepreneurship and
creativity and building the future so
i'm just gonna go over some of the key
points
that i think are really important and
give some of my thoughts on it
so the first thing that i want to talk
about is that the
the the central purpose is
for healing and that we really have to
take into account the amount of people
that have
debilitating neurological issues
whether that be anything dealing with
the spinal cord
and inability to move um or
whether that be with neurodegeneration
and the amount of people that we know
that have their
libraries of beautiful thoughts that are
just being
burned down and that we're not able to
to capture those and and and these are
these are critical concepts to
understand that there's so
much um miss neural communication
happening in our body that we want to
heal and augment ourselves with
and so that's first and foremost is that
so you've got to think about it from
that perspective if somebody
is blind or if somebody's having macular
degeneration
um if you know if you
the reason why so many people first of
all don't
care about these things is because it
doesn't happen to them
or it doesn't happen to people in their
family or people close to them
because as soon as it happens to you you
become an expert on macular degeneration
because you're the one experiencing it
so all you do is relentlessly go and
just
educate yourself online about it or
family members getting
alzheimer's and you're trying to find
every piece of information about how to
heal it
and this is the general trend that
happens is that
the the more that you try and and
empathize with the perspective of what
it would be like to have one of these
debilitating neurological diseases
the more you actually realize that you
want the world's best
neurosurgeons and electrical engineers
and computer scientists and ai engineers
and asic designers the application
specific integrated circuit
that you want these people that are
pushing the edge you want them to push
the edge really well
because then you can actually heal the
debilitating neurological disease either
for you or your family member
etc so with the more empathy you have
and the more you're able to get behind
the eyes of people that have
these debilitating neurological diseases
the more you're actually
able to realize how important it is to
have entrepreneurship and creativity
around
the cutting edge of neural engineering
so wake yourself up that way
to the importance of technology and that
will help you tremendously
um moving forward with the advancement
of the edge of technology rather than
the fear
you know and really bring up that meme
over and over again from like
120 or so years ago where it was the
meme of the people that were
fearing henry ford and fearing the the
automobile
and that they were such proponents of
consider the horses
remember how much better your horses are
remember the horses the horses the
horses
and the same thing with the wright
brothers and flying airplanes the
airplanes are the devil
airplanes are going to kill us blah blah
blah now there's a hundred thousand plus
commercial flights that happen every day
around the world
so it's just this endless cycle of this
as carl jung would call it it's an
archetype there's this archetype of fear
and then there's this archetype of
uncommon
entrepreneur the literally the great
founder theory of history
that men and women uh 1 billion
out of the 100 billion people that have
lived and died are literally the ones
that were most uncommon
that made the mutations the
augmentations
to our lives that give us this vast
abundance of beautiful things
and and and successful flourishing that
we have today so be the uncommon be in
that one percent in order to be there
you have to not have the fear archetype
and you have to have the
entrepreneurship and creativity
archetype that's very very important and
take that empathetic perspective from a
healing
point of view and that will help as well
with understanding why we're doing
projects like neural engineering one of
the one of the ways that i want to
that i want to bring this up that i that
i was surprised that it didn't that it
didn't come up
because people like aubrey de gray jun
yoon
we've had many people on our show that
have talked about
uh rejuvenating our our bodies at the
level
of the cell uh to the youthful
homeostatic capacity
so if you take your own body when you
were
15 years old or 20 years old you know
that you
like for me i played a lot of sports
right here's my
you know my high school boy soccer
shirt that i'm wearing right now and i
played a tremendous amount of sports and
what we would do is we'd wake up in the
morning
and we'd do two a day so we'd wake up in
the morning we'd go work out
run hustle play sports and then we'd go
to school
and then after school we would do
another
session of work out hustle play sports
so we'd do these two a days but the next
day you'd wake up and you would go
and do it again which was crazy because
now think about it if you're 25 if
you're 30 if you're 35 if you're 40
can you do two a days that shit's hard
and so
this is the idea is can you return the
body to its youthful homeostatic
capacity
and also can you do so in a way that
like
with the sense foundation um strategies
for engineer negligible senescence
they have a bunch of strategies right
now i believe around seven
around the key components around the
cellular
aging and how to actually rejuvenate the
cell at this again at the cellular level
how to make cellular communication stay
very strong
how to eradicate things like that
hayflick limit when the
telomeres at the end of your chromosomes
are unraveling
that the cell can actually divide more
than just the limited
what is 50 to 70 amounts of times
approximated right now so we have all of
these different
ideas about uh induced pluripotent stem
cells
right so we have all these other ways
it's not just neural engineering and
neural degeneration that we want to
heal and augment but that we actually
want to return the entire body
to homeostatic capacity at the age of 15
and 20 and basically keep it there and
that's what arbitrary
degree calls the longevity escape
velocity
so the idea is that you're tweaking your
body so well just like we do to
jet engines that have hundreds of
sensors on them that basically
you can uh you can live more than
one year for every single uh amount of
year that your body is degrading
so that's the the general idea is that
you want to be able to
um keep the youthful homostatic capacity
for
forever and then if you want to ever um
decide that you want to to to stop
living then you can choose
so so it becomes a choice rather than a
force
um and also didn't mention this too with
uh with neuralink quite a bit
that it is um
it becomes a choice basically to to want
to get augmented or not
it becomes a choice to get the upgrades
or not um
it becomes a choice to um
to have neurodegenerative disease or not
and you get to choose
moving forward okay let's see
um there were interesting bits that they
brought up that it's flush with the
skull these are all to start by the way
all these things are just start flush
with the skull
um megabit wireless data rate all-day
battery inductive charging overnight for
recharging currently a thousand channels
and it's only going to be improving
so they think that the neurosurgical
operation will take less than an
hour that you can leave the hospital
same day no anesthesia
fully automated robot to do the
procedure which is very interesting as
well that's good that we're moving into
that
step of robotic automation you saw the
way that the robot
was putting the electrodes into the
vasculature
how it's literally avoiding the
vasculature right you you because you
can't
hit the veins and arteries because then
you're gonna have bleeding
so you really requires that precision
and it's only five microns
um five millionths of a meter per
electrode and we'll see where that ends
up going
uh in the future and
it's also reversible you can take it out
if you want the digital signal
processing or dsp is super interesting
because it's kind of similar to when we
had
an episode on our show
when we were talking with um with big
tree
on our show over in china and it was
really interesting when he mentioned how
when you take the banana peel and you
bring it up to the fruit fly's nose and
you're watching its brain
it's live it's alive and you're watching
its brain you bring the banana up to its
nose
you can live see the neural architecture
firing as the fruit fly smells the
banana
because that's that's signaling to it um
its ability to
to eat metabolize and increase its
longevity because it's a food signal
and so it's very similar for us with our
digital signal processing
that we want to be able to visualize all
of our digital signal processing and
then not only be able to record that and
save it and access it later with memory
which we'll talk about
but also that we want to be able to
stimulate and that's how we stimulate
away
some of the neural neurological diseases
as well as some of the
the impediments with vision impediments
with our spine and
motor function this this type of stuff
and we use technologies like two photon
microscopy in order to visualize
at those levels those very very small
levels they got breakthrough designation
by the fda which was huge
i didn't actually know that they did the
last people that i heard that got
breakthrough
designation by the fda were well
back when we were interviewing rick
doblin for maps the multidisciplinary
association for psychedelic studies
which was huge
and then also i believe adam gazelli and
achille
interactive got an fda um
they got fda approved but i'm not sure
if they got breakthrough but they're
huge for
for playing video games to heal uh and
also to augment
our our fullest potential which was very
cool you can check them out they're
awesome
um then
again it's their own all of the hardware
and software is being engineered
in-house which i think is super duper
important for everything that's
for them moving forward um
a very simple way to think about it is
that if you communicate a
simple bit of information like these
words that i'm saying right now
and you take that little these little
bits of information
and all you have to do is think the bit
of information and then it gets
transferred to what you want to do for
example if you want to
send a person the message to not forget
to
to to send you back one of the proposals
or to pick something up from the store
or to if you want to summon your tesla
like they used in the example
that it's just that simple thinking of
that bit of information
and max hodak who is sitting next to
elon musk
who i got a chance to meet at the brain
mind summit on consciousness which was a
lot of fun
um he is really interesting because he's
he's really passionate about
consciousness and he really wants to
understand it and i think
he's one of the people that is kind of
he studied in philosophy
but he's even more passionate about
wanting to solve it from the perspective
of physics which i think is
really crucial as well because
i think the on the spiritual side on the
phenomenological side
consciousness is most first principled
but also
uh if you can simultaneity if you can
hold two perspectives it's consciousness
is most first principled but
consciousness also
did evolve in the sense of our evolution
of complexity that then enables
sentience to
to arise and realize this entire process
so it's that simultaneity
um that's very very important and so
we'll be um diving into that more
but he mentioned that um whether you're
going to be decoding
on the head or on the phone or on the
computer is very important to know for
now with a thousand channels you can
decode on the phone
um and later that you
would want to push it to the head
especially with quantum computing as you
gain
more and more computational capacity in
smaller and smaller
areas you'll be able to push more and
more
channels electrodes uh and their
computation
for both the recording and the
stimulating right there
on head and they use big spikes
to be able to detect to decode um and
take those raw waveforms in
and they didn't answer the question
about what the api will look like but i
thought that was a very interesting
question
what will it look like for developers to
be able to work with
neuralink i think that's really crucial
especially as we try and catalog all the
neurological diseases and then
be able to have the developer
communities be able to figure out how to
record out um the the miss neural
communication and how to stimulate in
the proper
neural communication for the healing so
that cataloging the api will be very
important for the cataloging and also
for the augmenting
um for me to be able to if i want to see
in infrared or if i want to see
in uh in ultraviolet or sonar or all
these different styles
of uh i would love to see these sound
waves that are coming right now it would
be so
interesting to be able to like like
click between the channels of all these
different perceptual
uh augmentations and then it would wake
us up faster to realizing who we truly
are why we're here the metaphysical
implications
of neurolink are huge um they also
mentioned that a good benchmark is
like a quadrup a quadriplegic person
being able to
um you know move around their body to be
able to even do things like
uh to be able to think a thought and
play a game
um to basically unleash the creativity
of every single
uh person no matter what the
debilitating illnesses are to bring them
back to that fullest potential that
that that peak homeostatic capacity um
again we mentioned these solving
blindness paralysis hearing
um all you and you can do all of that
from just three to four millimeters uh
into the cortex so right there at the
surface which is great and then at the
hypothalamus level you would need
obviously the longer electrodes to get
down there and you would need to not
[ __ ] up any of the vasculature along the
way
but you can cure depression anxiety
addiction
and
yeah the material sciences are really
hard the installation of these
electrodes that are just five microns
they're so so small and that's again
that's just five
millionths of a meter um or you can
think about it like
one five thousandth of an inch as well
and they want these to last for decades
which is really crazy that
you know that that's nuts how do you do
it from a material science perspective
to get you know the whole
uh the whole asic itself to not be
rejected when you plug in the neural
link but also all those little
electrodes that go in for the
body did not reject that but to have
that bio compatibility that was talked
about
is really important to make that last
for decades so that you don't have to go
in every year but that every maybe
um 10 years or so that you can go in and
get an upgrade
you know at the speed of technological
change it's going to be more often than
that like
right now how often are you buying a new
cell phone
every two years right you're gonna end
up getting a new neural link every two
years probably
and that's just gonna be the trend of
things and that's the way you're going
to want to do it because you're going to
want to [ __ ] be at your best
fullest potential and you're going to
want to see the world and all of the
beauty and complexity and creativity and
switch between these channels and have
the whole world
working on that future ai symbiosis
and not from a perspective of fear but
from a perspective of creativity and
entrepreneurship and love
that's the future
and then
yeah the material science stuff's also
nuts because they have to know how to
sense and record the signals and also to
generate the stimulation
to not corrode the electrodes to have
the thin insulating layers they want to
use silicon and carbide right
now oh this was interesting how to
create the least
amount of electrical pulse yet
have that be able to speak to the
neurons which was really interesting
so you want to kind of figure out what
the threshold is for the least amount of
stimulation but yet to do the
let's actually stimulate that neuronal
group which is super interesting
so there's a lot of
the in digital signal processing there's
so many things here
that i'm super unfamiliar with that i'm
very child level
on but some of the things make sense
like there's only a one
millisecond window for the signals of
interest for
these spikes and i think that's really
fascinating that there's just that one
tiny millisecond
uh window one out of a thousand in that
second
and that's super crazy that you have to
you have to sample at 20 times that
speed
in order to in order to be able to find
those
tiny little spikes spike detection at
900 nanoseconds
that's so freaking nuts
um so yeah that at that uh at that
thousandth of a second level wow um
and that's how you get the proper
readouts
and then i thought it was interesting
you're talking about this relationship
between the amount of people that
they're going to hire
at neurolink and also the amount of of
channels and electrodes that they'll
have so
you got to think about it like the whole
thing was about promotion
for hiring and so it's really important
the more of these greatest minds around
the world we can get around neural
engineering to heal and augment us
the more we can add channels electrodes
to the actual devices that then
enable all these beautiful future
applications that we want
so and they're hiring so many diverse
people which is great
and they're very they're an organization
that like that wants to teach people as
well
so you don't have to come in with a
tremendous amount of neuroscience
knowledge
either
and it's bluetooth low energy radios
they're sharing the 2.4 gigahertz
spectrum
which they talked about the importance
of um figuring out how to
make sure that the signal does not
degrade because if you're ever at large
scale events
concerts corporate offices just these
places with like you know hundreds or
thousands of people what you're going to
end up
realizing is that sports events that
you're going to realize is that the
signal degrades so you have to basically
prevent the signal degradation
which i think is very fascinating
figuring out how to
how to do that on an engineering level
it's really great the first clinical
trial is for spinal cord injuries which
is
huge um again remember to take that
empathetic perspective
and now really help you a lot um
paraplegics
just by thinking that they can output
words they can control their phone
um the computer and our friend andreas
forsland over at cognition is doing
really really important work on the
on the same side of helping people
without eye tracking and the in the
phone camera to be able to use
technology like imagine you can't move
but you can use your eyes
and move them around and then type words
like literally communicate with the
computer that way um for the computer to
know what you're saying
it's a lot like what stephen hawking had
and andreas forsland and cognition are
going to the next level so we greatly
appreciate them so much
shout out to you guys and
oh they were also talking about adding a
second um
neural link potentially at the base of
the spine which is really interesting
may act as a neural shunt you could
restore someone's full body of motion
which is
really crazy for people like you and i
maybe we have
hip lower back knee injuries right we
can actually potentially
restore ourselves to that again that
peak youthful homeostatic capacity which
would be so badass imagine yourself at
30 35 40 45 50
and you're still able to run for miles
and you're still
you know you're really able to to feel
like
you have that youthful homeostatic
capacity that child-like
ability to to be physically active which
is huge
um they're dealing with a lot of issues
with the uh with the chemistry the
biochemistry of that region
inside of the skull there's pressure
obviously there's the there's all the
intracranial pressure that's going on in
that area and so they have to deal with
that there's a lot of influences
from the body on that area they're
talking about saving and replaying
memories which is very interesting if
you think about it from when you were a
kid how many memories do you remember
from when you were a kid
very very few and it would be so [ __ ]
cool to go back and the technology today
like this is really
enabling parents to take photos and
videos of their kids
that they're then in 20 years gonna be
able to show them but we didn't have
that
right growing up in 1990s we didn't have
parents with the these types of devices
doing that but kids growing up in the
2020s they get their parents having the
devices taking all the pictures and
photos
that then 20 years later they can go
look and be like i remember that memory
right
but in the future it'll also be
literally just your ability to recall
the memories
and to record them store them and then
recall them because think about it when
you're feeling a little bit down
you can both get stimulated to go back
up you can also go visit
the memory catalog and go and go back to
all these great memories
you can store these memories like a big
civilizational library of alexandria
where
all of the humans that ever live
starting from the year maybe 2030 onward
that we literally log every single
memory of every single human which will
be super interesting to go back and
catalog
and analyze and understand creative
patterns of genius and all these other
types of things which are super cool
uh they have their animal care program
which i thought was
it was pretty interesting that they were
using pigs i think that
it's really important that we do you go
go up to pigs and then
we can potentially i don't know where
they are with primates or not i don't
know
but i think leveling ourselves up beyond
mice and fruit flies and stuff is
super important so that they're at pigs
already is is very important
um and that we're doing the rounds of
testing there is huge
huge um in terms of coding c c
plus plus java python they mention that
it doesn't really matter
what method you're using as long as
you're getting [ __ ] done fast which i
thought was really important and that's
a really
important lesson for youth is know how
to be polymathic and be creative fast
and not necessarily be tied into a
specific way of doing it
um yeah again
on a physics level understanding the the
um the idea of a neural correlate to a
state of
phenomenological state of consciousness
is a fascinating idea and to be able to
use physics to prove that
um they made a funny joke about if you
bombard earth long enough with photons
it'll emit a tesla
like that's so funny um because it did
honestly did
go in this evolutionary process of
hydrogen to sentience
and but also you hold that
simultaneously with that sentience is
actually most first principled and we go
through this evolutionary process where
sentience arises
consciousness is first principled and
consciousness arises
both you can have both simultaneity is
key
[Music]
and that's that metaphysical idealism
that we talked about with bernardo
castro and rupert spyra and so many of
you there's
so many of these other leaders uh go
watch those episodes if you haven't yet
our interviews with them
and they think that the starting cost is
going to be somewhere around five
thousand dollars or so
um which would be which would be great
um that's such a
it's a that's a pretty uh decent amount
of
of that's a really low cost to start
regarding
such an advanced level technology and um
that's really kind of like the the cost
of like the modern day
uh like super high-end computers that
people use for
um for for animating and for
um video and for um
gaming and ai and cryptocurrencies like
mining
so it's actually a pretty decent cost a
mark and then it'll also be driven down
significantly over time
um again the visual prosthesis for eye
injuries
gaining supervision we talked about
throughout
telepathy the idea that again that i'm
just spending so much of my time trying
to put
the concepts into words and then shoot
them across here and then
for it to enter into you and for you to
compute what i'm actually thinking
uh when i say the word simultaneity is
key with consciousness or when i say
another concept like metaphysical
idealism
for that to instead of use words to
communicate that concept for that to
really land telepathically in that
conceptual telepathy
is super important non-linguistic
conceptual concept consensual telepathy
it's
really interesting um and it's a huge
part of our future
and then they also mentioned trapped
creativity which we've been talking
about and that we're really passionate
about the fact there's just so much
latent creativity that's just trapped
within us that we can potentially
unleash our fullest gifts into the world
if we actually
just had that tiny bit more neural
stimulation
regarding um healing our our depression
anxieties worries and also in fears and
stimulating out our entrepreneurship our
creativity our fullest potential and our
gifts to ourselves our family or
community in the world
we're going to learn a lot about
neurological disease and how to heal it
which is going to be awesome
um there will probably need to be a
little bit of
as we eradicate as much suffering as we
can and increase as much well-being as
we can there's probably going to need to
be a little bit of fear
like in the sense that like if you are
off rock climbing and you have no fear
that you you may take a leap that
that that the probability of you
succeeding there
was actually a little bit low and that
you shouldn't have taken that leap
because you didn't have enough fear
so i think that's a really interesting
point as well that it's not just all
binary in one direction but that there's
got to be maybe a little bit
of that in place and that also speaks
heavily to what we're talking about
right now regarding safety
and security um it's not the idea that
no fear is the way to go
it's it's not saying that somebody a
hundred years ago saying that
you know watch out you might die trying
to fly those first airplanes it's not
saying that that person
shouldn't have said that it's saying
that that person is right regarding at
least bringing
up like really make sure this is
engineered well make sure it's
engineered safely the airplane make sure
it's engineered
so that people don't get injured and die
and the same thing's true
all the way up to today with neurolink
um but
there's the way it's like a proper
polite
way to talk about that little bit of
fear and it's not
fear mongering that's not the way to do
it um
i think i've learned a lot from people
like david ike and alex jones i've
learned a lot from people like them um
and i think they have some valuable
things to say right right we're parsing
for that signal
um and and not so much the noise but
that ultimately that's that's i think
the way to do it is to take these very
serious ideas about
making sure that that people are healthy
and happy and flourishing and it's safe
and it's secure just like
the people were saying it about
transitioning to automobiles
transitioning
to um to airplanes transitioning
to i don't know if you guys remember
thomas starcell and the burden of genius
one of the great films
um but same thing with liver transplants
right everybody was saying don't do it
you're gonna kill people
um it's a horrible idea and now today um
you know he's the father of the modern
day transplant surgeries
because he was the one that pioneered
that forward with his team and whatnot
and so it's the same idea all the way up
to day-to-day with neurolink you can
take that tiny little bit
of a fear that's that's intelligently um
brought forth and just said
you know this is how we're gonna get
through that those issues around privacy
and security
but also we've mentioned this in so many
of our episodes before that really it
also boils down to um to
our ability to enlighten ourselves and
get to a universal basic stakeholding
um across the board and the more that we
enlighten ourselves the less downstream
malevolences we even have to worry about
so you don't actually have to program
security and safety and all these
worrisome issues
downstream because you're actually
enlightened on the most
upstream and so the more enlightened
people we have the more enlightened our
global leaders are
the less we'll actually have to worry
about the downstream issues around
safety and whatnot
we want to coexist with these advanced
ais we want to have ai symbiosis
we want to have an ai version of
ourselves to be able to like play
a tennis with on leveling up our fullest
potential into the world
um these ai coaches it's a big part of
our synthesis
and
yeah basically the future of earth
becomes the sum of our collective will
and where we want to take things
and that's pretty much it this has been
a bit on neurolink
a bit on healing remember take that
empathetic perspective
with healing all of the different
neurodegenerations
and also same thing on uh the
augmentation
and the potential to maximize this take
into account the fact that these are
entrepreneurs and creative people that
are building the future
um when you see so much of today just
caught up in the bickering
in the center of the evolutionary pacer
really try and rocket yourself out like
one two three standard deviations out to
the edge
where it's really these entrepreneurs
and these creatives and these scientists
and these artists and these
leaders these spiritual leaders that are
really trying to push
they're trying to like basically pull
the rest of the evolutionary pacer
forward
because they themselves know that the
idea of making the mutations making the
augmentations in our civilization
in the full unleashing of the
individuals is really what's
crucially important and not so much all
of this bakery
so just remember that and support um
people like that around you and become
that
uh yourself at a deeper level so um
yeah that's pretty much it by the way
all the stuff everything that's
happening with neuralink
is also similar to what's happening with
vr
with ar with simulation theory with
artificial general intelligence it's all
converging all of what the west is doing
and even now
obviously with china and japan and these
other technology powerhouses israel
saudi arabia europe and whatnot just
there's more technology powerhouses
globally that are converging on the same
thing
that eastern spirituality had for the
longest time
been talking about um so it's it's it's
just turning into one big
oroboros it's it's really all
triangulating on
um a deep amount of of of metaphysical
idealism
around consciousness around what we
talked about with donald hoffman and
conscious agent theories a very
interesting proposal you can check out
that episode on our channel as well but
that it's all triangulating and to
really hold that at the forefront that
you are this unique individual with
gifts to bring to the world but you're
also part of the one
and that we're all part of that one and
that seems to be the prevailing
hypothesis that we're moving forward
with western tech advances and eastern
philosophies merging together so
love you very much thanks for tuning in
and
we got this we're building the future
beautifully
we got this we got this um
turn up the creativity turn up the
entrepreneurship turn up the execution
turn up the focus and we're gonna build
the more beautiful future
our hearts know as possible so you guys
know what to do
comment let me know your thoughts
subscribe if you haven't liked the video
share it with other people get people
passionate about leveraging neural
engineering to heal and to augment us
and i'll talk to you guys more soon
synthesis is gonna be published
we got less than two months left i'm so
pumped it's looking so beautiful it's
super visual
and it's super short it's super visual
and super short i'm very pumped
if you guys check that out so big love
i'll talk to you guys soon